il connaît le célèbre doc l'un d eux
confesseur de fun radio
vous appelez était docteur christian
spitz et vous publiez sutil questions
d'adolescents aux éditions odile jacob
des lettres de jeunes gens qui veut
qu'ils ont été adressées vos réponses à
leur angoisse à leur appel alors
curiosité et enfin mon invité de
référence c'est françoise héritier
anthropologue spécialiste de l'afrique
professeur au collège de france
directeur du laboratoire d'anthropologie
sociale vous avez succédé à claude
lévi-strauss auquel vous dédiez votre
livre intitulé les deux soeurs et leur
mère sous titre anthropologie de
l'inceste publier ce livre aussi chez
odile jacob
françoise héritier d'abord appelez-nous
succinctement ce qu'est ce que c'est que
l'inceste que tout le monde connaît et
alain c'est ce que tout le monde connaît
c'est simplement le rapport sexuel entre
deux parents alors un père et sa fille
une mère et son fils tout le monde sait
cela mais ce qu'on ne sait peut-être pas
de la même manière c'est que sous le
même nom d'un cesse sont rangés des des
interdits y compris dans notre culture
et dans notre droit et pas seulement
dans le droit canonique en droit civil
qui sont des interdits qui porte non pas
sur des parents par le sang et sur des
parent par alliance
oui et c'est à dire des personnes qui
n'ont rien de qui n'ont pas
nécessairement de lien de consanguinité
avec vous et pourtant qui tombent sous
le coup de prévention de l'inceste se
voit donc dans le premier un test c'est
donc des gens qui ont des rapports de
consanguinité et dans le second se
plaint c'est ce qu'ils appellent dudus
du deuxième type ce qui d'ailleurs une
bonne des finances européens se sont
donc d'aider un cesse de de parent par
alliance c d inceste de parent par
alliance d'une part mais c'est aussi une
plus profondément
l'explication par les parent par
alliance vient masquer quelque chose de
plus profond qui est en fait
l'interdiction pour deux personnes qui
sont de même sexe qui sont apparentés
une mère et sa fille par exemple d'avoir
un même partenaire sexuel l'ours est
interdit c'est surtout celui qu'on
appelle des deux soeurs et l'on retrouve
dans des grands pans de notre histoire
et de l'histoire de l'ère disons assez
mythique qu'on retrouve également dans
beaucoup de régions du monde
et qui est qu'une à cannes interdite qui
est fait pour deux soeurs par exemple
d'avoir le même partenaire soit lorsqu
elles sont toutes les deux en vie soit
la mort si rennes est morte et que
ensuite il veut épouser leur innovation
et leur mère les deux soeurs et leur
mère alors et cela vient d'un cela vient
du plus anciens textes que j'ai trouvé
qui est un texte hittites c'est-à-dire
qui remonte au deuxième millénaire avant
jésus-christ et qui codifie et tous les
interdits matrimoniaux et au milieu de
tous ces interdits matrimoniaux qui sont
édictées pour un homme se dise que ce
qu'un homme ne doit pas faire donc
épousé dans sa tranquillité il y à un
dernier interdit qui est tout à fait
surprenant qui dit qu'un homme ne peut
pas avoir en même temps et en un même
lieu les deux soeurs et leur mère alors
la question qui est posée est ce tu vois
ça paraît va montrer libidineux mais la
question qui est posée par l'historien
allemand qui a fait l'analyse de ce
texte est tout à fait pertinente il dit
c'est quand même curieux on ne dit pas
que cet homme est marié à l'une ou
l'autre des ces trois femmes
on ne dit pas que ces femmes lui on est
dit on ne dit pas par nos par ailleurs
que lui même est marié à quelqu'un
d'autre et que les femmes sont mariées
ce qui serait un délit d'adultère et on
s'aperçoit que ce sont des femmes qui
sont parentes entre elles et qui ne sont
pas parenté avec l'homme en question
alors qu'est ce qui est exactement
reproché et l'historien allemand ne
savais pas quoi en fait c'est ça la
série 2e tiff dont c'est le deuxième
type que vous avez repéré alors dans des
dans des écrits hittites grec et
l'hébreu biblique et c'est la loi et au
fond ce que vous voulez ce que montrer
dans ce lit c'est l'universalité de 2 de
ceux de cet inceste du du deuxième type
et son histoire et son historique il
sait d'universalité de cette recherche à
le montrer le prouver historique - et
ethnologiquement sa deuxième partie de
mon ouvrage mais j'ai cherché à le
montrer également sur le plan
anthropologique dans la troisième partie
je cherche à montrer qu'il ne ne peux
pas ne pas exister il ne peut pas ne pas
que cette idée de l'inceste ne peut pas
être présentes ne peut pas ne pas être
présente dans toutes les cultures et
d'entre eux il ya un texte alors qu'il
célèbre qui vient à votre secours c'est
lévitique parce que la politique est un
texte très précieux
il est comme
il est fait pour ça alors le par exemple
le 11e verset dit l'homme qui couche
avec la femme de son père et il a
découvert la nullité tillon de son père
il a découvert la nullité de sang de son
père
c'est à dire un père et un fils et se
sont rencontrés dans la même femme
donc le fils qui couche avec la la veuve
ou la femme de son père du vivant de son
père parce que ça pouvait arriver
eh bien il découvre non pas la nudité de
cette femme mais il dit bien la nudité
de son fer sérique il découvre
l'intimité paternel parce qu'on peut pas
parler d'une sorte de parenté du sperme
si c'est exactement cela c'est l'idée
l'idée fondamentale c'est que le le
rapport sexuel est un échange d'humeur
des fluides du corps transit d'un corps
à un autre et il en reste quelque chose
et donc de deux hommes qui se partagent
la même femme comme le disent les nuers
ils se rencontrent dans la même matrice
donc bon donc c'est ça ce qu'on appelle
c'est la vraie définition
alors l'homme qu'est toujours dans les
mythiques l'homme qui prend une femme et
sa mère c'est une publicité on roulera
pas le feu lui elle il n'y aura pas d'un
huissier parmi vous est ce si tu ne
découvrira pas la nudité de la soeur de
ta mère ou de la soeur de ton père car
c'est d'un du déni des sa propre fille
on ramène toujours rappelle que zohra
soit au niveau personnel
c'est à dire il dénoue de la nudité de
sons et des voix la nudité de son père
et comme son père s'est lui même d'une
certaine façon parce qu'elle d'identité
persiste c'est comme découvrir sa propre
dévissé et est à deux ou trois versets
gandhi ainsi découvrir ta propre dignité
le verset après deuil et devient très
drôle parce que c est l'homme qui couche
avec sa tante il a découvert la nudité
de son oncle helvétique dit tout cela de
façon extrêmement nette est extrêmement
précis mais il n'y a pas si longtemps
finalement les sabots si vous le montrer
que la que ce soit la loi française où
le droit canon
ne m'interdisent plus ce genre de la
scène ils interdisent toujours à bon au
moins en ligne directe la ligne de
filiation directe c'est-à-dire que vous
ne pouvez toujours pas épouser la veuve
de votre père ou la femme divorcée de
votre père qui ne seraient toujours très
vite dans vous avez du bois l'homme est
ce que c'est ils sont versés qu'en
lisant votre livre chaque fois pour
revenir en arrière pour dire à ce que la
soeur du long de la femme du père il
n'est pas votre mère et votre belle mère
oui oui bien sûr c'est quoi votre
belle-mère c'est aussi la mère de votre
femme c'est pour cela je suis obligé de
préciser
donc vous ne pouvez pas épousé la mère
de votre femme vous ne pouvez pas non
plus et épousé la mère la femme de votre
vie avec mon ski est très intéressant de
votre propos c'est que en fait vous
allez bien au-delà de ce que vous dites
c'est à dire que vous allez bien au delà
de 2 les change d'humeur dire que vous
préciser les limites de ce qui est
humain
les limites de ce que les limites que
l'humanité ces données elles mêmes à
travers les grandes traditions
spirituelles pour définir ce qui est
humain ou ce qui ne l'est pas et en fait
ce que vous dites c'est que le sexe à
une valeur sociale et qu'il joue un rôle
social et ça c'est très important à dire
aujourd'hui je crois important tout de
même été biologique d'ordre était
religieuse c'est à dire que de ne pas
procréer avec quelqu'un de sa famille
c'est simplement éviter des maladies
génétiques
lassé par ce problème c'est de démontrer
ces deux démos de trouver une théorie de
l'inceste qui rendent compte de toutes
les catégories interdite
or les théories de l'inceste en général
et explique les prohibitions sur l'a16
elle ne rencontre pas qu'elle ne rende
compte que 2 les interdits portant sur
les parents consanguins parce que quand
on vous parle de tard par exemple qui
pourrait survenir après des mariage
incestueux il est bien évident que un
mariage incestueux avec un allié
n'apporte pas de repos de rapports de
consanguinité
en fait il ya deux sortes d'inceste en
fait 1,7 entre adultes peu importe la
ligne et puis la cèze des mineurs et ça
il faut peut-être pas oublier tout de
même que c'est un problème dont je dis
pas ça pour vous
en général c'est parce que j'entends
très très souvent l'inceste et millet la
cct est masquée il ya énormément
d'enfants qui sont réellement cassé dans
la révolution psychologique parce qu'ils
vivent à 7 avec une personne leur père
ou même leur beau père est là il ya une
assimilation au total et ça c'est plus
qu'une réalité c'est une chose de très
très grave car je suis parfaitement
d'accord
simplement je voudrais pas que mon
client ait confusion vous c'est de l'art
il a une théorie anthropologique général
de l'idée nationaliste et non pas oui
mais les dix jeunes
j'ai trouvé un cas qui va dans notre
sens mais qui n'est pas dans votre livre
en lisant emmanuel de confesseur j'ai
trouvé un cas d'inceste du deuxième type
auquel on ne pense pas souvent cas
évidemment un petit peu scandaleux mais
qu'est ce qui ne l'est pas en matière
d'inceste c'est le cas à dieu ne plaise
ou un confesseur viendrait avoir des
rapports avec ça qu'on fait c'est cela
constitue non pas un péché de sacrilège
mais a pêché d'un sas car il s'agit est
au 17e mais non de vérité alors c'est si
on pousse pu voir votre raisonnement est
ce que l'on peut dire qu'un homme qui
fait l'amour avec sa femme enceinte de
ses oeuvres comme un inceste à la limite
à la limite on pourrait le dire et
certaines personnes particulièrement
raffinés dans leurs esprits en plus le
penser comme michel leiris
mais j'avais déjà plus loin il ne veut
pas il voulait plus faire l'amour avec
une femme qui lui avait donné un enfant
après la naissance est là c'est qu'il
disait il sentait qu'il y avait comme
une commune comme une relation
incestueuse qui s'établissait au sein de
la famille à partir du moment où ils
continuent à avoir des rapports avec la
mère de sa fille ou avec la mère de
santis
tout simplement qu'il assimile à de
merde et à sa mère à sa propre mère
iliad si vous voulez des fades et façon
raffinée de voir la chose je cite michel
des risques on pourrait citer d'autres
personnes qui ont également d'aider des
sensations d'inceste dans l'essonne en
eau dans les limites conjugal alors vous
cherchez des exemples alors d'un jour
monte et pas seulement aux critiques
dans l'actualité vous prenez un
feuilleton qui est passé l'année
dernière sur tf1 qui s'appelle les
coeurs brûlés ok vous a repéré un ascète
deuxième temps et puis l'actualité nous
a fourni ces fonds au fond il a beaucoup
beaucoup plus tôt et doit dire non c'est
à dire dans une histoire comme celle-là
ce qui est formidable c'est que les
scénaristes ont voulu mettre des
situations scabreuses
mais tout ce qu'il trouve comme
situations scabreuses il ya aussi un
insecte véritable d'un oncle sur sa
nièce c'est au départ c'est le 1er mai
tous les autres c'est des situations
scabreuses parce que tout se passe entre
multiples familles mais quand on étudie
chaque adam chaka des rapports
successifs se sont tous des incestes qui
deuxième tiff
oui il est fatal aussi que les uns c'est
du deuxième type soit plus fréquents que
ceux du premier parce qu'on peut le
connaître à 1 502 savoir un peu comme
être aussi celui du prg ou est ce un
bien sûr n'en fait plus rarement quand
même un second l'a souvent que des
alliances que vous améliorer dans des
sociétés différentes de la nôtre on peut
commettre assez souvent là c'est du
premier type quand les interdits sont
beaucoup plus propres plus large que les
nôtres mais sans le savoir alors mais
pour répondre à votre question de tout à
l'heure vous disiez dans la loi
française est toujours interdit donc
dans la filiation mais en revanche ce
qui a changé et très récemment c'est
pour les collatéraux les parents frères
et soeurs et notamment c'est en 1914 qui
a été rendu possible que rendu possible
le mariage avec les pouilles de sa femme
décédée en 1981 qui rendu possible le
mariage avec la soeur de son épouse dont
on a divorcé
chris lye est dans le droit canon c'est
seulement en 1984 est rendu possible ce
même mariage après naturellement le
décès de l'époux ce weel donc c'est très
fréquent c'est 95 et dans l'histoire
anglaise et j'en fais vous voulez dire
un peu mais s'ouvrira dans ce livre
il ya l'histoire d'un débat qui a duré
entre 60 ans et un siècle pendant le
parlement la chambre des lords justement
sur cette question de savoir si on
pouvait autoriser un homme épousé la
soeur de son épouse
et puis en l'actualité vous a fourni
alors un exemple extraordinaire
évidemment sur lequel vous vous penchez
sont les amours de woody allen et de
sony le saunier elle s'appelle alors
expliquer ce qu'il y a un ce est plus
parce que évidemment au début on a été
gêné quand on appelait histoire parce
que tout le monde s'en dire le mot monde
a dit est-ce qu'il ya pas un inceste et
speak il n'ya pas d'inceste réellement
on ne peut pas dire cela mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est la manière dont vous
dit allen s'en défend et les
commentaires qui ont été faits dans la
presse et notamment américaine en disant
c'est pas de la cesse et c'en est
presque et il avait parfaitement raison
de dire de cette façon et vous dit allen
se défend en expliquant premièrement il
n'est pas l'époux de mia farrow mais
seulement son concubin capitaine
écossais il met en évidence seulement la
lien biologique et unique lien social
en revanche il met en évidence un
rapport purement social entre mia farrow
et sa fille adoptive et 10 était la
fille adoptive de mia farrow qui
emmènera sa fille biologique et en plus
ce n'est pas la mienne et et par
ailleurs je n'étais pas le mari de mia
farrow mais seulement son petit ami est
donc dans ces conditions et je n'ai pas
pu dire on ne peut pas dire cesser une
relation incestueuse parce qu'elle était
majeure
parce qu'elle aurait des ménages
rappelle que la loi française le
beau-père une relation entre une fille
et son beau père est assimilé à sa
récente estieu 16 très important de dire
société américaine d'une part et puis
bon il mettait en évidence un certain
temps et est la même chose s'il avait eu
saison il aurait été condamné 13 rbs que
le scandale n'est pas venu précisément
de ce que les gens ont l'impression
qu'il y avait quelque part avec la
majestueuse alors qu'elle n'existe pas
au sens propre mais ya quand même une
relation incestueuse pour les raisons
qu'il rit je ne suis pas je ne suis pas
le mari des mia farrow dont je suis pas
le beau père et sa fille et sa fille
n'est pas une fille biologique je suis
sollicité sur le rôle maternel
une relation qui ne fait défaut c'est la
filiation est aussi assurée par
l'éducation l'alimentation comme une
prise en commun la prise en charge si
c'est une histoire itab histoire d'amour
entre sept filles et garçons s'il n'y a
pas un excès de pouvoir de ce père parce
qu'il a joué le rôle de père personne
n'a jugé je crois que c'est ça qu'il
faut dire non expliquez-nous pourquoi
pourquoi vous at on attendu pour
débusquer quand même c'est un 16 du
deuxième type c'est quand même c'est
quand même une découverte extraordinaire
parce que vous remontez à des textes non
ils sont disponibles
les textes sont là sur la fois qu'on a
dit la chose par exemple dans hamlet et
éviteront les terry d'antan rue d'ypres
waro faillite et dont les textes sont ja
qui assure la prise de position je crois
que je vais vous dire une chose que
gênant de le dire mais c'est peut-être
parce que comme on m'a dit monsieur lévi
strauss j'ai un certain talent pour
découvrir des choses cachées
bah oui c'est vrai le aimé le ski
embêter ce que vous n'avez pas dit
peut-être se prêter de le dire c'est que
vous avez découvert c'est un seul
deuxième set dans l'eau burkina faso où
vous êtes vous avez étudié les
civilisations les sociétés a commencé
ces las vegas
c'est vrai que ça commence et c'est là
que je me suis posé des questions devant
des situations de parenté des situations
d'alliance et des rituels qui avait lieu
entre des personnes qui me paraissaient
surprenant alors que ce soit chez les
samoa ou chez les baoulé detry par
pierre étienne ou chez des populations
madagascar décrit par un autre père
j'avais moi j'avais observé des choses
que des collègues avaient observé et des
cris et dont on ne comprenait pas la
rationalité et la teneur par exemple des
rituels pour réinstaurer la parenté
entre une mère et sa fille entre deux
soeurs qui ont partagé le même
partenaire sexuel c'est à dire hey you
know une est mariée à un homme et puis
vous savez que la la soeur de son épouse
la fille de son épouse bien c'est les
deux femmes qui doivent s'être illustré
en fait que doivent subir à sacrifice de
l'illustration et ce sacrifice de
lustration est d'une nature assez
sanglante puisque c'est en général d
aspersion par deux victimes
sacrificielles etc les baoulé c'est
notamment un agneau où on m'assure
opérant deux dont les deux femmes se
tiennent chacune une moitié dont elle se
frappe jusqu'à être ouvrir 200 mai
partenaire masculin et or hors de cause
il n'a rien à voir là dedans et le
problème de la deûle insert existe entre
les deux femmes
ces deux femmes qui sont considérés
comme étant en relation incestueuse du
fait d'avoir partagé ce partenaire
sexuel comme un paon c'est pas possible
à donner mauvaise conscience à certains
qui nous écoutent peut-être qu'ils y
tient monsieur j'ai connu je suis en
train d'en des relations incestueuses un
deuxième qui s'est évidemment plus que
vraisemblable d'autant que dans
certaines régions de france il était
entendu comme en bretagne que le mariage
avec ben thanh hommes devenaient veuves
c'était le mariage avec sa belle soeur
la soeur de son épouse qui paraissait le
meilleur mariage possible pour les
enfants c'est ce qu'on disait aussi en
angleterre et dont il ya eu beaucoup de
mariages qui était contraire à la loi et
qui était cependant fait dans certaines
régions qui présentait ce mariage comme
le meilleur ce remariage comme le
meilleur simplement parce que et les et
les curés fall et le supplément les
appels en bretagne enfin et les curés et
les maires ignorer purement et
simplement la loi il ne pensait pas
aller contre les lois dont il ne
demandait pas de dispense c'est là on
retrouve effectivement entend les angles
dans l'état civil un certain nombre de
mariages de cette sorte qui prouve tout
simplement que ces relations là peuvent
très bien ne pas être vécue comme un
inceste et se trouve simplement que dans
l'ensemble de l'humanité c'est si je
puis dire la relation qui est primordial
mans incestueuse ce qui fait que la
relation la première interdite c'est
celle où il y à des individus qui ont
deux qui sont des sexes différents qui
peuvent sa part y est évoqué la
possibilité d'une la génération enfin de
l'engendrement donc la prohibition de
l'inceste n'existe que pour des
partenaires de sexes différents
elle n'a pas besoin d'être édictées pour
des partenaires de même sexe qui sont
cependant des parents 7
cette parenté par les humeurs dont vous
parlez beaucoup j'aime beaucoup ce mot
humeur quelques ont employé modèle
autrefois on a dit qu'il espère mme de
la bestia le lait
il y a le sperme il ya le sens il ya le
lait ou les humeurs vaginale il y à
toutes sortes de choses devant tout ce
qui passe d'un corps à l'os qui parle
d'accord à l'eau et qui donc est compris
à salives y compris la sphère et tout ce
qui n'est pas encore assez d'aisance ico
logiquement que ça se passe si on
regarde d'un peu plus près d'eux mêmes
c'est le docteur moi je me mets sur un
plan anthropologique et je regarde
comment les choses sont apparus au début
de l'humanité et plus et je montre tel
que nous vivons toujours selon les mêmes
moules les mains droites de rationalité
de la mode de raisonnement sérénité
incroyable d'usure millénaire constant
dans les interdits pour fixer l'humanité
dans un cadre qui lui permet d'être plus
humain de se construire
[Musique]